developing right now at 40 investigation
into what exactly led up to a
22-year-old man being shot and killed in
henderson does continue
right now we know at least two suspects
are in custody nearly 200 miles away in
arizona 8 news now's david charns has
more on what
witnesses say happened henderson police
say they got several calls of people
being
shot at early thanksgiving morning it
ended here at this 7-eleven parking lot
where a 22-year-old man died then those
suspects were on the run
not even 30 seconds later i heard maybe
three more gunshots
and then right after that another
sequence probably two or three after
that
and i'd say there was probably a total
of maybe 12 or 13.
neighbors like melissa wells say they
heard the shots and knew something was
wrong
in addition to the young victim four
other people were hit in these random
shootings
at least one bullet hitting the outside
of that 7-eleven
shattering this window police say at
least two people were seen in the car
that got away
a man and a woman with tattoos or paint
on their faces
later thanksgiving day more shootings
more than 100 miles away from henderson
in la paz county arizona
sources there tell 8 news now they
believe the pair is connected to
shootings in the small towns of booze
and parker it ended with a shootout with
police
those suspects taken into custody now
because police tell us there were
several shootings
before this young man was killed in this
parking lot and there were reports
of gunshots around town they do want to
hear from any witnesses
you can call police directly or you can
report anything anonymously to crime
crimestoppers
we're at lake mead in sunset in
henderson i'm david charns 8 news now